Olá! Nesse vídeo eu quero esclarecer alguns conceitos que geram muita confusão na cabeça
dos pacientes, que são a definição e a diferenciação entre as medicinas funcional, integrativa e estilo
de vida. Eu resolvi fazer esse vídeo por causa de um acontecimento recente em que uma médica
o objetivo não é criticar ninguém, é simplesmente dizer que há muitos colegas mal formados que não
fizeram residência médica, que somente fazem cursos de finais de semana ou cursos rápidos,
e muitos deles têm uma rede social grande ou muito desenvolvida, se auto-entitulam médicos integrativos
e começam a divulgar várias informações falsas ou mesmo repetidas de outras fontes sem realizar
suas próprias avaliações e estudos e acabam cometendo infrações, às vezes sem querer, às
vezes por ignorância e às vezes por má-fé. Esse tipo de colega acaba, pelas suas atitudes,
sujando toda uma classe de médicos de boa-fé que tenta realizar uma medicina de alta qualidade.
Lembrando que o Conselho Federal de Medicina não reconhece essas modalidades funcional,
integrativa, estilo de vida como especialidades. Eu mesmo não as trato como especialidades,
mas sim como estratégias ou filosofias de tratamento, e esse é o jeito que eu acho
correto de encarar isso. Em termos de especialidade médica, eu sou cirurgião-geral e urologista,
formado há 27 anos, membro certificado do Board da A4M, American Academy of Anti-Aging Medicine,
mas eu tenho várias outras formações que não vem aqui ao caso falar. Bem, voltando às medicinas
funcional, integrativa e de estilo de vida, cada uma oferece uma perspectiva única sobre saúde e
bem-estar, focando em tratamentos personalizados e holísticos, ou seja, enxergando o corpo como
um todo. Então, geralmente essas três modalidades se complementam significativamente
quando realizadas corretamente de forma ética pelo profissional. Toda vez que aparece um colega
nas redes sociais com atitudes erradas que acabam sujando o nome das medicinas alternativas,
a imprensa vem duro com uma atitude muito crítica e com razão. Porém, eu quero lembrar vocês que
existem muitos médicos ortodoxos, alguns deles com uma reputação muito grande dentro de grandes
hospitais que praticam atitudes antiéticas com muita frequência, como indicação de cirurgias
desnecessárias ou outros procedimentos baseados simplesmente no lucro, seja lucro pessoal ou lucro
da instituição que representam. Só que esses médicos são altamente protegidos pelo sistema
porque geram altos lucros para as grandes farmacêuticas, para os grandes hospitais e
para os grandes grupos de saúde. Então você não vai ver a imprensa metendo pau nesse tipo de profissional.
Bem, vamos às definições.
[Música]
A medicina funcional é uma abordagem centrada no paciente que busca entender e tratar as causas
subjacentes das doenças em vez de apenas focar no alívio dos sintomas. Ela vê o corpo como um
sistema integrado, onde cada órgão e processo estão interconectados. Então baseia-se no conceito
de que a saúde resulta da interação dinâmica entre genética e ambiente, incluindo dieta, estilo de
vida e fatores sociais. Então, por exemplo, em vez de apenas prescrever um remédio para dor de cabeça,
a medicina funcional investiga fatores como alimentação, estresse e ambiente e como eles
estão influenciando ou contribuindo para o problema. Então dentro do ambiente, um fator que a medicina
funcional leva muito a sério, por exemplo, é intoxicação com metais tóxicos pesados,
poluentes orgânicos persistentes e outras toxinas biológicas. E isso é geralmente totalmente ignorado
pela medicina mais ortodoxa. Então como ferramentas, a medicina funcional utiliza histórias detalhadas
dos pacientes e testes avançados para criar planos de tratamento personalizados. Geralmente
também ferramentas em medicina ortomolecular, fitoterapia e uso responsável de hormônios
bioidênticos isomoleculares quando é indicado. Então essa medicina está fortemente basada em
estudos científicos, mas geralmente não são divulgados esses estudos nos congressos médicos
oficiais de especialidades, porque são fortemente financiados pela Big Pharma e pela
indústria de equipamentos médicos.
[Música]
Já a medicina integrativa, por sua vez, é um termo guarda-chuva abrangente que engloba muitos
estilos diferentes de medicinas alternativas, o que pode gerar confusão e com razão entre pacientes
e outros profissionais de saúde, porque ela combina muitas práticas diferentes, como práticas de
medicinas tradicionais milenares, é o caso da chinesa, ayurveda e tibetana, com métodos alternativos
e complementares, como as práticas e várias modalidades de homeopatia, visando também o estar
total do indivíduo, mente, corpo e espírito. Então a medicina integrativa reconhece a importância da
relação entre profissional de saúde e paciente, utilizando uma variedade de terapias, desde
acupuntura, meditação, terapias baseadas em energia, como imposição de mãos e terapias
quânticas. Então parte dessas práticas é fundamentado em evidências, enquanto outra
parte carece, sim, de literatura científica. No meu consultório, na minha clínica, eu pratico
parcialmente esses conceitos das medicinas alternativas ou complementares, ditas integrativas,
e eu opto por não utilizar modalidades sem estudos científicos, embora eu respeite muito quem as pratica.
Já a medicina do estilo de vida, ela concentra-se na prevenção e no autocuidado, promove mudanças
nos hábitos de vida para prevenir e tratar doenças crônicas. Então baseia-se em seis pilares,
nutrição, atividade física regular, sono restaurador, manejo do estresse, evitação de substâncias
nocivas e conexões sociais positivas. A prática, então, envolve educar e motivar os pacientes a
fazer escolhas saudáveis, utilizando para isso técnicas de coaching, intervenções baseadas em
evidências para alterar comportamentos e melhorar a saúde a longo prazo. Então cada uma dessas três
abordagens destaca a importância de tratar o paciente como um todo, considerando os múltiplos
fatores que influenciam a saúde. Então elas três, medicina funcional integrativa e estilo de vida,
elas se complementam, oferecendo diferentes caminhos para que os indivíduos alcancem e
mantenham um estado de alto bem-estar, prevenindo ou gerenciando condições crônicas de maneira mais
eficaz e personalizada. Então se você busca uma forma mais completa e proativa de cuidar da sua
saúde, considere essas modalidades, medicina funcional integrativa ou estilo de vida. Isso
pode ser um excelente começo, mas é muito importante que você escolha profissionais
sérios. Procure se aprofundar no conteúdo que esses colegas divulgam nas redes sociais. Tente
não focar simplesmente em aspectos mais superficiais, como aparência física, ou se a pessoa se expressa
bem, ou se é uma boa oradora, ou se ela se veste bem, ou se ela está em um ambiente luxuoso. Então
procure ver se essa pessoa fez residencia médica mesmo ou outra formação equivalente de longa
duração. Que lhe proporcionou a oportunidade de aprender em um ambiente de hospital ou grande
ambulatório pela prática e com supervisão de médicos mais experientes, e que essa pessoa tem
que fazer várias provas durante essa formação. Procure saber se ela estudou para obter um título
de especialista reconhecido pelo Conselho Federal de Medicina ou mesmo pelo MEC, o Ministério da
Educação. Então tenha muito cuidado com os profissionais que só fazem curso nos finais de
semana. Cheque as informações de currículo com detalhes. Perca tempo com isso que vale muito
a pena. Obrigado por assistir. Se você gostou desse vídeo, não se esqueça de curtir e compartilhar.
Até a próxima. Você é fera! Um grande abraço e um beijo no seu coração.